well you know I think that literature is
one of the necessary human studies
because the beginning of human wisdom is
to recognize that you know where you are
the product of of history that millions
billions of people have lived before us
they've already lives that are
startlingly similar to ours even though
they were in different places at
different times what literature allows
you to do is to create a conversation
with the past and the present out of
which you can imagine and create the
future and so it gives you a sense of
the reality of other people's lives from
the inside from the day leanness of
their existence not only in their peak
moments but in their ordinary moments
and what that I think does is build
compassion it builds humanity and it
builds a sense in a sense of what the
changeable parts of human nature are and
what the permanent parts are
you